please welcome genius and Gifford Cairns
The Mastermind behind this
tournaments to tell us like how did you
came up with this idea because I know
that you support a lot of scientific
events classical music events and then
the chess event well basically the real
real people behind the scene was
Joy Bray
and Shannon Bailey and they decided we
needed a top women's one
then they decided they had to name it
after me because we had the sink field
so that's how it happened you know
because we wanted one that celebrated
the best women's players
and this tournament is about to become
traditional we had a small break through
the historical this was the third time
in a lot of the players actually they've
come here three times
I think we only had one who had never
been
yes so she's she's playing the
tournament for the first time so how
does it feel it's good it's it's
interesting when you watch the women's
games versus the men's games
it's different they tend to be
in some ways more interesting because
they're not playing you know you're
memorizing thousands of old moves and
they're and all of a sudden you you find
these things that they're
emptying the board you know and you're
going what's happening and so it's just
a different style
which I enjoy you know fireworks yes on
the boards yeah fireworks yeah and from
what they've seen in the previous
editions of the Kevin's cup they there
were a lot of decisive games so the
percentage was skyrockets and at some
point you were having more than 68 of
the decisions yeah it was like someone's
gonna win you're not gonna
you know try to play to a draw you're
playing to a win and if you have to do a
draw you might but you're going to try
to win I wanted to ask you about your
book read and write chess and I also
contributed in a small way to this it
translated you fancy the French please
tell our audience about it and about the
purpose okay the it's a booklet where
you can start with very young chess
players to teach the literacy in other
words how to read and write chess what
are the letters for the pieces what's
the location for the board what are the
how do you write down the moves because
you could I could play chess without
reading and writing but if I want to get
better if I want to play in a tournament
if I want to be able to read a book or
even replay my games
I have to literacy and since I served
that chess merit badge what we were
finding we had what 300 000 Scouts that
were in the chestnut badges the kids
aren't in the right place they're not
maybe in a big city that has a big chest
influence there are no coaches you know
of course so I wanted a broader group to
be able to learn
you know what Wesley so did tied himself
by learning and literacy
and then I don't know we
got translated into one language and now
it's in how many languages more the last
ones were okay Romania okay that's
Christian shower right he just persuaded
the uh
Ukrainian I'm sorry Romanian we also
have Ukrainian okay Romanian Chess
Federation
to use it in the public schools
because the learn to read and write
chess besides being available in all
those different languages is free
you get a
there we go that's the English version
okay there's we got Uzbek Armenian is
new
Romanian
Russian Swahili English French German
Indonesian Filipino Romanian
we have to find another exotic I just
need to you know I find
Grandmaster chess players or high chess
players who
come to me and then they put their name
on the front
so now we're teaching chess literacy and
in Eastern Africa this is a very unique
future and Dutch and Dutch
yasu's wife did Death
so that was it's fun and because we want
to find and grow chess players from
around the world
I agree with you that's fun I actually
tried it with my own daughter and you
know yes we did the whole project from
the beginning Until the End yes to help
you make it a better booklet right how
old was she well she was seven at the
time yeah see this was a seven-year-old
helping her write it in a seven-year-old
it's designed for
children you read write say move all the
literacy and and the other is it's just
going outside of chess
in St Louis there was a former football
player NFL
Demetrius Johnson I just had a way he
coached four high school football teams
he required every football player to
learn to play chess
because he felt it helped them visualize
to improve the pattern recognition well
remember you got this set of moves okay
we're going to play this route right
sort of like a chessboard
uh Jenny I wanted to ask you a question
of course everyone knows that Rex is so
passionate about us so are you well tell
me how do your games go you know if you
play we start playing 50 years ago okay
he's a I don't like to lose and he's a
terrible loser
so there's no upside for me if I If I
Lose I'm not happy if I win
he's not happy so I'm not happy so I
don't play him I'm willing to play
others
but not him uh Jeannie I don't remember
I told him he could do chess I mean how
expensive could it be
and I think that yes sir wants to ask
you a question can you create something
uh Genie it's not really a question
so much as a compliment I just want to
say that this tournament I mean I've
been calling all kinds of tournaments
but this tournament in particular with
the top female players has always been a
great pleasure for me so I wanted to say
thank you simply it's a great tournament
thank you you have to admit it's they
play to win they do indeed they play to
win and that's a different world I don't
know if you notice in this game
you uh unless you have a three you know
thing for a draw
yeah you can't offer you can't offer a
draw in this game yeah I think it's a
very important feature although I do
believe they don't need an extra
motivation you know yeah
this is a motivation play to win
so
yes thank you very much oh I'm going to
tell people out there if you haven't
been to St Louis
or the state of Missouri you got to come
and
to celebrate 200 years of the state of
Missouri
I had a eagle scout build a
5 000 pound 15 foot square Bicentennial
chessboard which has pictures of
Engravings of 200 years
but we have people playing in the
capital all the time by walking out of
the Capitol and going down to the park
yes we're finding Grove chess players
right of course Saint Louis is the mecca
well Missouri is okay we stretch out a
little bit right
so thank you so much Daniel for all your
efforts and I just wish that they would
continue for many many years and
remember we got to keep translating new
hungers I'm looking for
Tamil and Hindu and
Italian and Portuguese
thank you thank you Genie indeed now Tom
Holt I mean we might in Hindi we might
just have the players here to do the
next step let's just